it's 1229 a.m. I'm gonna try and keep
this quick but I did want to do a video
explaining fantasy chess for the protest
League if you're watching and you don't
know what the protest League is you
should it's one of the biggest online
events taking place and let me open up
the website I don't usually record my
whole screen but hopefully people can
see this this is protesting calm it's a
seasonal league which takes place on
chefs calm and there are just a number
of top players in the world who play
there's teams from all over the world
and every week there is fantasy chess
where you essentially try and predict
who will perform the best
and then there's prizes and assuming you
get all the like predictions correctly
you can win $10,000 so this is what I'm
gonna do I'll fill out my fantasy chests
if you want to call it a bracket or a
Google forum but I'll go ahead and click
here open in a new tab and we have this
this Google forum I'm actually gonna
split screen the window so we'll have
this open in one-one portion of the
screen and then I want to bring up the
pairings which are also pretty important
so if you're on a Mac you can do this if
you're on a Windows computer you should
also be able to do it so there's an
explanation here your score is a total
points of the 16 players that you pick
and I should explain the formats it's a
team versus team kind of formats for
this week and every team has four
players all four players on one team
play all the other four
players on the opposing team and the
players are ranked from board 1 through
board for there's also for four
different divisions 1 2 3 4 different
divisions so essentially we have to
choose the top performing players in
each division on each board which brings
us to 16 different categories so
assuming we get all 16 players who
perform the best
then we'll win $10,000 or all win
$10,000 I've actually already placed in
the top three for two previous weeks
which won me a one-month Diamond
membership which I've actually already
given away to two people but I'm gonna
share some of my like tricks and
strategies for having a competitive
brackets so to say so we're going to
start with just basic info I'm going to
type in my email address but I'll
probably edit this out so now people
can't see it unless I forgot to edit it
out hopefully that's not the case
just calm username people can see it's
just iron rosin and now we'll start so
Atlantic Division board 1 first I'm
going to expand all the pairings and
just see who the board ones are Fabiano
Caruana pops out yvonne Sarich pops out
one of the top performing players in the
league and okay so we can see this list
of players and what I'm looking for is
strong board ones who are playing
against relatively weaker lineups and
I'm actually very inclined to pick
Sarich for this one because there's no
player above 2600
on The Sopranos so you could very
possibly go four out of four Fabiana
would have to play a Liana of and a
terrazzo go to two very strong players
I'm going to open up another tab which
will give me some some other insights I
want to go to the players tab because
now we can see like performance ratings
so if Fabiano is a top performer in the
season
sarch should be up here I think we're
Sarge Sarge where are you oh he's here
yeah Sarge started off the season
completely monstrous I think he beat
fought me on though actually in one of
the earlier matches we're gonna pick
Sarge and move on to more - I think
board - should be Wesley because Wesley
has I mean a rating advantage over
everyone on this team unless I'm missing
anyone maybe Miranda there's an argument
let's check Miranda solid player I'm
gonna go with Wesley as Leslie can
easily go four out of four or still be
the top scorer
okay so we have Sarge we have Leslie
abort three I will say I'm more
knowledgeable about players in the
Atlantic Division and some other
divisions so some of these will be
easier for me to the side for this one
I'll probably have to do some research
Alejandro is an attractive pick I think
this is his first time playing though
Alejandro for the archbishop's because
he should beat like these two players
and then if he can scrape off points
against the top ones I'll score about
50% Alejandro has he played and he
matches
oh he's performed terribly wait no
that's not the real alejandro imposter
Oh Alejandro has not played any matches
so I was up in the air
anyone else an eco check this is a solid
lineup from the chest bras who's Andrew
Horton no geonji weighing definitely not
see as he's playing monster players yeah
I think I'm gonna go with Ramirez
there's also Balakrishnan but he's
playing my team the Webster windmills
and we have actually a very solid lineup
yeah let's go with Ramirez and that
leaves us with the board for who I think
I already know who I'll pick Arron
Korbin ski he's I am strength
I think he's underrated because this is
a September rating
he's definitely stronger than me and
he's playing against players who he can
all scrape points off of so that's
Atlantic Division I will make a note if
you want to copy my lineup exactly I
guess you're free to but there is I
think a rule that if two players qualify
or two like fantasy people qualify to
win the $10,000 the money is split and
the money actually comes out of Greg's
ahadees pockets so I would highly
encourage people to fill out a bracket
because the more brackets or forums that
are filled out the more likely Greg
Shahadah has to to pay out someone but
it is very unlikely like to pick 16
correct players not miss a single one
it's not easy so Pacific Division board
one moving on let's expand these
pairings I'm just gonna see who's
playing any super GM's
doesn't look like there's any super GM's
a lot of 26 hundreds I think so far Lee
pops out I think so far Lee is one of
the top performers in the league if I'm
not mistaken or maybe he's not where's
the Farley performance rating over 2,700
yeah the ratings I look at are the
performance ratings and not necessarily
the September feed a ratings and he's
playing against a beatable lineup cerana
oh Serrano how's he doing in the league
also doing pretty well have one very
tough opponent that being Dre of looking
for beatable lineups actually narrowed
its key oh wait I'm not picking aired
its key because this is a like Minnesota
has very strong players not picking and
rooting there's also an argument for
this guy Xiao Jing Chou this is very
close Xiao Jing Chou his performance
ratings too low and then there's also
Wang yeh Wang Yu Wei how's he doing
ooh very high eight-and-a-half out of 11
he's very experienced he played in the
approach s League finals but this is a
strong line-up sluggers yeah this is a
close call I'd probably either pick one
you a or safar Li I'm gonna go with my
gut and just say so Farley board -
looking for names that stick out anyone
over 2600 on board to any one man is
this is these are more balanced lineups
than the Atlantic Division take on
Petrosian
I think this guy is the highest rated
let's check his performance rating
joo-young you nothing too impressive
Petrosian it's a good name for chess
2644 but it's a strong line-up from
China Illingworth very prominent chess
coach not doing that well in the league
I think we can eliminate him
so Jiujiang you is a candidates house
Gaurav it's doing corvatz
I already picked Safari though so it's
awkward to pick orbits but let's check
oh he's doing quite well actually a
tough call Michael Brown
[Music]
just checking performant rate
performance ratings yeah Michael Brown
performance ratings too low and for two
from Minnesota actually bored to Stevens
irk let's check zerk not bad but he's
playing such good players yeah again
it's a toss-up korilla gorillas
currently playing in a tournament which
is interesting he could be warmed out or
he could be printouts did I say wormed
out warmed up wait let me check
Petrosian again I'm probably going with
Petrosian 2644 and let's check China
again Zhang yeah let's go with Petrosian
that was a close one
board three let's move on I'm tempted
just to go with Nick cough he's old I
think the only GM on board three Oh
margvelashvili - okay so I think it's
just a toss-up between margvelashvili
2570 performance rating 2464 maykov yeah
twenty five seventy performance on board
three is very good so we're going with
Marg do I play it in the tournament once
we play that the collegiate Final Four
we drew a long flight so that's actually
good because I haven't picked any
Chinese players I picked two here so
these two can do work
we'll see board for as beers din who's
the board for for Minnesota Oh Jacobson
how's he doing in the league Jacobson
who new player I mean based on reading
he's probably a good pick all they're
one to consider is Brandon Clark who's
actually very good in rapid like we when
he's in for him he's in for him I played
him a few times in Australia very
recently yeah let's go with Brandon he
should win at least one game if not no
he shouldn't win at least two games just
curious his performance I know he
performed very well last year Brandon
Clark
oh he hasn't played the game yet this
season well okay hopefully he's somewhat
warmed up yeah I think he's the best
pick so moving on Eastern Division and
I'm aware maybe this isn't the most
exciting video for people but the
prospect of winning $10,000 should be
somewhat exciting and I'm like I take
this seriously at least I try to and I'm
trying to show my my research process
even if it's not the smartest thing to
give away my secrets so hopefully people
are learning something from this okay
moving on let's expand these pairings
and okay these are like the European
divisions where I I know less players
embarrassed to say I don't know he's
like any of these names - well Gupta is
probably like the strongest player I
would think or no oh no he's not so I'm
just looking for rating differentials
Oberon how's oprand doing 2667 let's go
and order it mature ok Oberon is still a
good pic I think mesh Cobbs Chagaev I'm
just looking for performance ratings
over 2600 soft chenko maybe also a good
pic and not a new player and ponzu
whatever his name is
so I think there's a toss-up between
Savchenko and Oberon Oberon has a
slightly higher performance let's look
at the lineups Oberon playing all low
rate of players and oh he's playing
against South janko's team let's pick
overran I think that that should be one
of the best picks moving on board -
again probably what I'm gonna do is just
the same approach there I have this list
open and then we'll just search for the
names Teresa kion whoa 2700 performance
training I met him in San Francisco at
the protest League finals last year I
played him many years ago in the World
Youth Championship where he won the
competition I played him in the
second-to-last round on board one he's a
good player I think let's not waste time
let's just pick him people want to do
more research maybe you'll find a better
option who's he playing against yeah I
playing against okay decently strong
line-up but I think he's a good pick for
a board - very experienced board three
board three I'm aware of this player
diga who I think is one of the strongest
board like one of the strongest board
threes or whatever in the league on 2659
performance rating this is why you can't
always trust like the actual ratings you
have to look at performance to see how
they fare and in rapid and online so I'm
going with Giga board for let's look
here Volkoff is I think another like
easy pick let's just verify over 2500
performance rating is uh is September
fee day it's like 2100 something but
some players are just like specialists
in rapid okay so that was a quick and
painless let's move on to Central
Division last one we have more matchups
and Isla grovelling lagravis not playing
I should say MGO
I got excited there I saw Maxime so
let's start with board one board ones
wait he is playing why am I not seeing
his name lagarde oh there he is I just
see I saw Maxime Lagarde and just
assumed that was MBL's team we have to
pick em vo
sometimes he streams though and when he
streams he doesn't play like a hundred
percent like MDL but he's still just
massively strong he should be towards
the top of the league yeah yeah still
performance rating abort - I don't
recognize any of these names I recognize
trigger Boff let's do some searching
Admiral 2,500 performance don't chenko
move don't chenko only played one match
so that's another thing to look at like
this could be an outlier but still it's
strong results who's he playing against
don't chinko all lower-rated players
let's just pick him because I won't
sleep a new opponent or new new board
koehlers is a GM rights board 3 he's
actually higher rated than three players
on this team let's check his performance
over 2600 I'm just going with him last
board of again names I don't recognize
so let's search roll whoa 2560 who's he
playing roll aha
he's playing a strong line-up though
let's look at the other players I might
still go with him but I should at least
check who's below him Hana mm not high
enough Jose
not high enough Sara now high enough
diamante nope
who nuke I think this player was like on
the verge of beating MDL in a past week
but then MDL just pulled a miracle no
and no okay so I'm going with Liam so
there's my responses anything else to
say oh yeah one more thing to say
hopefully people are watching until the
end of the video maybe I'll make a pins
comments the schedule is let me go to
schedule the first matches are starting
what's the date today
today's a six so the first matches start
in the afternoon Pacific time which
means if you're gonna do fantasy chess
you have to do it within a few hours of
this video being uploaded I'll probably
make this like app in common and make
this in the video description if you are
watching this video and fantasy chests
like the forum isn't available you can
still do it for previous or for previous
but for future weeks just stay
up-to-date on the protests League
websites and if you go to this little
button here
it usually takes you to the appropriate
place apart from that anything else I
want to say yeah follow the protests
League
it's exciting to watch there's a bunch
of people streaming it's on on Twitch
I'll be streaming commentary tomorrow
for the or later today for the Webster
windmills our match starts at I should
know
sometime in the afternoon Chicago time
actually if you want to see my my
schedule let's go to IM rosen.com
/schedule and you can yeah you can see
the times here so we play the Pittsburgh
pawn grabbers I'll be streaming live on
Twitch and and yeah I just find more
information on Chesley comm so hope you
guys enjoyed that and thanks for
watching